we all crave our grandmother's cooking
right well what if there were a place
that you could go anytime and get that
home-cooked meal from anywhere in the
world
9:00 to munch on ice and mangia that
place exist in Staten Island just behind
that scaffolding right over there meet
Joe he's Italian by way of Brooklyn my
name is Jody scarab Ella and I own
Enoteca Maria we don't employ chefs we
employ grandmothers would you look in
the restaurant in 2006 you noticed
something every culture was coming to
the restaurant to celebrate these
Italian grandmothers so I thought to
myself unless would it be who celebrated
everybody's culture and so none of the
world was born there are probably
somewhere between 30 and 40 grandmothers
from different countries my name is
Teddy Bock I from Nigeria my name is Lou
both women from Moscow Russia
cataleya vengo de Lima Peru - Sri Lanka
hello Gary Kaplan Ireland from our menu
we decided attention dinner each night
there are two grandmother's cooking one
is always Italian the other from
somewhere else when they're in the
kitchen cooking it's a completely
different energy it's their day to shine
it's their day to show what their
cultural cuisine is all about you know
it sounds kind of corny but they do cook
with love and then feeling for Jose
about more than the restaurants when I
opened the Enoteca I was really
grief-stricken
my mom and my sister had passed it was
comforting to have these grandmother's
in the kitchen cooking and you know they
would pinch my cheek and say you want to
try this and at that point I realized
that what we were doing was much bigger
than I thought it was going to be when
you walk through the restaurant if you
listen every table that you pass by
they're talking about their mothers well
they're talking about their grandmothers
it kind of evokes a trip down memory
lane we've been called crazy a lot of
times by a lot of different people
we were coming with something that
nobody had ever put on the table before
so people didn't know how to react my
name is Camila Sadler we're in Bolivia
in the past restaurant gusto where I'm
the executive esta su su is crazy
restaurant on a mountain it started out
as a small culinary school projects and
then we decided to go back founded by
globally celebrated chefs close Maya
gusto is a unique culinary experiment in
social outreach the goal proving that
food can do more than just feed people
it can educate and inspire one of the
poorest countries in Latin America but
with an abundance of diverse and obscure
ingredients Bolivia seemed to be the
perfect spot to set up shop the idea of
giving something back in a development
country is where it moves to come things
with a picture Guster's goal is to train
a new generation of the Libyans to cook
prepare and serve high-end cuisine using
only Bolivian ingredients
this is not meant to be a typical
culinary school it's meant to be a
learning-by-doing Institute education
needs to come with with care you can
educate somebody if you don't care about
them
[Music]
mi nombre sorry Oh Phineas pasa
solamente soy supervisor Adiemus eros he
tambien us toy info condo más en el área
decimal eres es el momento en que Sentra
aqui es que todo es product o bolivianos
que ningún otro lado de vamos van table
or table so Y ver que boost to low edge
boosts to a cambiado merida there's a
lot of potential there's a lot of energy
there's a lot of pride one of the big
things we're doing is empowering people
here it's a movement that that touches
the whole society
[Music]
ta-dah Ananda revista de una mentira
hovitos areola Milligan Clemente hot
para
hey okay no my yoga book I read Alec
Kelly and I in the center of Havana is a
pair of entrepreneurs for taking Peter
delivery to new heights
yo soy Malta uno la mesilla en marcado's
Tom ahoy so Hawaiian ceremony at Casa La
Jolla Tampa a principal a Bahama polical
era Los Copa piccola Pisa caminando
destiny no cancel amo mucho y la gente
no pueden delay Leia a foodie idea taken
a cesta Baja lapis for a Baskin 2010
monster number one and her husband were
granted a private business life and
opened up a pizzeria a few months ago
her husband passed away now her best
friend is helping her keep the pizzeria
alive Paris Area say Amma Amma Moneda
por que usted tiene la pizza a la manera
cuya beno so develop em since then the
pizzeria which operates our motto number
ones roof has filled countless stomachs
with their secret recipe primera vez
esta en la maza en a salsa Iike a potato
tomato bruschetta kappa jerez de sus
ottoman era en la defensa sacred Oh s
toasty hemos tratado de mantenga Nanaimo
cheapo a masa de lama said manuel de la
guerra de la pista in d2 tiene más de
una de la gente de playa famous video
player anivia ago hasta la vista a yo
kwon bukiyou allah in Tortola Villa
Taverna
ever since Martin number to join Martin
number one in business to have form the
true partnership guys oh my god are you
okay
temperate Rizzo doc Ellis Oh Sabrina me
Elena nano so the bouquet bouquet garni
Sofia Larry Diaz in a zone Rita DNA
dreaming the one great big story in here
mama we made it everybody say that
better my mom's walking into this I
think we we got our grandma's cooking
for us
no this is us we did that right yeah
that's young man trap is is take risk
and prosper and that's what we go into
here so I hope you eat is tribe kitchen
15 shrimps in the bag that tribe kitchen
is a spot where you prepare products to
be distributed under ground we just use
that mentality with food we're a
full-blown catering service you also can
order for delivery during the week my
team consists of myself and three other
guys are calling my brothers my boy AWOL
DJ keV and bad news we're a small team
but we get the job done all the time you
know I mean we've always Crips and
bloods I mean when I kind of stuff
of course I'm getting arrested every
other day for nothing
shooting at it so now the only thing
we're worried about is some fool burning
looks like I'll run it out that's it
let's talk to my mom you got to do
something I'm like okay well what can I
do I seem that record our blue
commercial on TV I'm like then I look
kind of cool I probably do something
with that I know like you make good
money cooking I'm motivated started
culinary school and that's where I began
to practice my craft you know he really
came in here my babies tealight broke
what we gonna do like we need some money
I said wait we can sell some food
through Instagram I was like posting my
food and people's like all that looks so
good it looks great and I like okay now
it's time for me to offer this food to
the street like hardy boy pushes though
you know K and it worked the key to our
success we never gave look now every day
I saw I think about it talking we
improve our company how can we improve
our food how can we improve the taste
even though I'm reading the house
capping off like it's a real restaurant
[Music]
you
[Music]